that's one thing to this idea that here
we get in the theology Jesus was a
liberal there's nothing about him that
was I mean he wasn't no no he wasn't
anything I just can't and the DNC links
we're gonna leak think he's an atheist
and that to me is an incredible
distinction because there is in there is
no way in hell anyone in Europe and I'm
not strong Britain anyone in Europe
would be like right well you know we're
gonna get Bernie we're gonna get our
political opponents by revealing that
they're an atheist right I mean that
would reflect badly on the person who
said it yeah it would be if someone said
oh by the way that guy over there he's
not nay theist he's Nathan people like
what are you saying before that's weird
just go away if we really don't care I
mean this the thing this is the
difference and I always it always just
it grates on me in fact whenever I say
in American politics when you guys told
my god you told my god quite a lot yeah
and it's just like God and a British
politician would never bring up God just
just it would it would be the end of end
of the conversation and everyone would
be like why is he bringing this up you
know it's weird yeah it makes less sense
to for the Democratic Party since that
is you know that is distinctly the
atheist wing right now I think that's
changing we've talked about that listen
man I make you know and if you want to
you want to you know hit me on my Chris
yet people do all the time I'm a
Christian I'm pretty open about it I'm
always willing to discuss it then we've
had good discussions but I have talked
with not get jaded about this we have
less in common with a lot of young
Christians because they've sort of
switched we're atheists were all liberal
because of the abortion issue and now a
lot of young Christians have the Bernie
bumper sticker because they think well
Jesus talked about sharing and so I
share more common ground intellectually
with a lot of younger atheists because
they're becoming more libertarian and
Christians are becoming more left
whereas it used to be the opposite I
don't know if that makes sense if that
is ya know it makes sense now I know
you're talking about and
this is something I always found very
weird about the United States you you
seem to be the least Christian Christian
country ever I mean like if one was to
look at the life of Jesus you would
think that all of your Christians would
be Bernie Sanders supporters no no no
not not killing the baby up until
conception and you know no freedom and
that's two issues that's not like know
everything everything about it though
it's you know being a total that's one
thing to this idea that here we go to
the theology Jesus was a liberal there's
nothing about him that was I mean I
wouldn't know no he wasn't
okay the justification on that one okay
how exactly does a rich man get into
heaven well you're talking at a parable
which almost eat through the eye of a
needle right so it's like taking it
revelations very literally whereas when
you look at the literal it's really okay
very several examples of money it's it's
it's concerned from the poor and the
downtrodden and the advice to the rich
is to give you wealth away and go good
key advice there right what did you just
say the what for the rich the advice for
the rich their Dean a verse an advocate
of a system of government on forcing the
rich so second I said you just said
advice for the rich and I would I think
that's true and that's why wealthy
Christians give far more than any other
group on on earth but it's not a system
of government for the rich no right so I
don't think this is really yes so you
you would think that you you would think
that Christine's would be a lot more if
I live like Jesus then I'm being a
better Christian what I think more
Christians do if you look at charitable
giving and you look at serving their
community I think Christians the reason
why a lot of our conservatives is they
don't believe that government will do
that more effectively so they take it
upon themselves so I don't see it as a
Christian worldview to here there's
nothing charitable about spending
somebody else's money about stealing
money and spending it so that's the is
this the argument Jesus would make well
Jesus was actor asked directly about it
and he never made an argument in the
favor of a system of government he
deliberately avoided it
I know he what he was not involved in
government but well he was an
anti-government basically I mean he was
put to death not just because of
religion he was put to death for you
know going against the political
establishment of the day and that's as
the pharisees sadducees totally like the
system if you talk about like today in
the banks they were completely
intertwined with government back then
they they were the the Romans didn't
have any interest in Jewish squabbles I
mean they didn't care that there was a
Jewish heretic that the Pharisees wanted
for defin Pontius Pilate even just
shrugged and washed his hands and said
look this isn't anything to do with me
didn't he so there was a germophobe -
that's the part that's they didn't have
hand sanitizer around no I I think this
is an important point though because
it's often tossed at Christians and
that's what's created a lot of young
Christian liberals it's it's just not
accurate you know one of those things
that I mean and this this is the thing
that I always try to contrast with Islam
its Christianity is definitely sort of a
bottom-up religion you know it's it's
obviously it's concerned about the
poorest and most vulnerable and what
good can be done for them whereas Islam
is very much top-down prescriptive
authoritarian and so when people are
just like wow all religions are the same
aren't they so no they're completely
different and only only someone who
doesn't know anything about these
religions would suggest that maybe
they're all the same just because
they're religions it's like saying all
governments are the same because they're
all government's notes right silly it's
just totally uninformed and it really
annoys me hearing it yes we hear time
yeah well I think actually I think you
just sort of in a roundabout way made
the case for why Christianity would be
more libertarian and Islam will be more
communist let me allow me to explain
because as you're talking about
Christian is from the top from the
bottom up right so a good example with
Islam why it's spread by force socialism
communism at the end of the day can only
be applied through force through
government force through violence at the
end of the day if you don't do this the
government is going to send in men with
guns whereas the idea of self-governance
of libertarianism can only be done
through free will which is why if you
look in Europe you see a lot it like I
said secularists they give far far less
they're far less charitable yeah where
they
bigger governments in the United States
much smaller government but people are
exponentially more charitable and I
would say that that's a big part
particularly when you take the stats of
the Christian right those are the most
charitable people on earth whether we
like it or not okay I think I mean
libertarian is probably not really how
I'd phrase it I mean if anything I mean
Jesus sounds like he was running a
hippie commune you know so nobody tell
people that go buy a sword yeah well
well let's not even go into it because
then then we get into what's valid and
what's not in the Bible right but yeah I
mean generally at least by Saul of
Tarsus is estimation he he seems to have
been a bit of a hippie commune leader
whereas Islam is a lot more like fascism
and where every Muslim is a Nazi not
that I'm saying Muslims and masses
hashtag all Muslims Sargon said it that
trending Sun but it creates the
dichotomy it creates the very ugly us
then where Christianity doesn't really
have that yeah I think like you said
like Islam is much more prescriptive and
it's pretty clear their system of
government and law and this is the
difference this is this is what makes it
tough and I understand why atheists have
issues with Christianity and and I think
there's a misunderstanding of the
separation of church and state doesn't
exist it's not in the Constitution but I
understand why a theist can get leery of
people using their faith I get mad not
gay Jared I talked about it when
politicians use it to pander on the
other side like okay you're clearly
lying about it the difference with Islam
and Christianity and I think you're fair
to make this comparison I think I think
we're tracking here's Islam is
government hat religious hat theology
hat Community Hall is one with Christian
okay this is my faith these are my
morals and then at some point national
security you take off the religion hat
the faith hat and put on the American
hat I mean it is directly in line with
what Jesus said render unto Caesar what
Caesar's render to God what is God's
right that you could not get a more
blatant distinction and a more blatant
endorsement of secularism from Jesus
Christ right you know you could you
couldn't get a more distinct like
cific endorsement of secularism and how
Christianity shouldn't be running the
state right from his own mouth whereas
Islam is completely the opposite what I
think the term secularism like a good
examples United States was the first
country to really do that right like no
church in England but faithful was way
more it was a secular state I mean the
the queen is the head of the church and
she's that of the state so you're
technically not a sec so technically
that is a much more secular nation but
obviously you know people people you
think so if any politician brought up
God no it would be the it would be
silence in the room until someone
insults another man in Parliament I've
always thought that was funny well yeah
and they argue about civility and then
it states in like have you ever seen
Parliament there's something almost
about just going hammer and tongs at
each other so you ya know it's an
interesting dialogue well that's what I
would say you know when people say kind
of like you have a qualms with when
people use the word liberal right I sit
with comments like well on a second even
if Jesus were like a hippie commune on
his own he never advocated that for a
system of government I didn't so which
is what which is what social Warriors
are super guilty of doing they take
Matthew five and say oh this is a
prescription for government turn the
other cheek right now don't defend your
country don't you know no borders that's
efficient for the individual individual
it's a very individualistic kind of you
know turn their cheek you know if
Stevens a jerk to me I would probably
there's no getting around that
Christianity teaches better morals as
well I mean there's no I mean Denver
wrong there you you know if you were
going to compare them to in a sort of
warlike way they're definitely weaker
you know they're you know turn the other
cheek when you've been struck by your
enemy sure it's not gonna win you any
battles but it's certainly a lot more
high-minded right well that's also out
of context though to libel historically
that was a challenge that was a slapping
of a glove
turning the other cheek that was a duals
I you know cheek that's what it was la
people understand that entirely and if
you read the Bible later on I mean it
Jesus could turn you the cheek because
he was perfect right so it a perfect
cheek to turn it's a little different if
your cheek is pockmarked and marred yeah
but he's still setting the example he's
setting the tone yes he's suggesting
like if you're going to be perfect then
what you do is you don't do violence you
turn them chicken was it Simon who cuts
off
the Roman centurions II yeah Simon you
know what that's something yeah yeah
just like stop it hey this is a nice man
we talked about we talked about this
that's another thing too you know he
will know as a kid you know his
traveling student stanch kid I was I was
17 remembers in New York with a comedian
and you're saying you know what the
opposite of love is fear in the Bible
fear is the equivalent to hate I'm gonna
know that's actually not true cos think
about it you talk about that with the
ear chopped off I've never gotten to
with a pastor this is again we're just
of whether people believe it or not I'm
saying I think what is a parable Jesus
was very afraid before this idea if you
read about it saying hey if I don't have
to do this if I don't have to be
crucified please let there be another
way and that was another thing as a
Christian I get mad being grown up
because I'm terrified of a lot of things
and and I people say well if you're
afraid that means you don't have God in
you because God doesn't allow you to be
afraid and so I think a lot of
secularists here this BS and they think
that all Christians agree with it and
I've never read it going well gosh this
seems like Jesus is afraid here like he
doesn't he seems like kind of scared of
being crucified so it is okay um and and
that is something where it's just you
know again these the same social justice
words you go ideas was a communist like
you should never be afraid well no you
should be afraid if so wants to chop
your head off
yeah it's irrational to suggest that
someone shouldn't be afraid of their
impending death the funny thing is like
there are there any two types of people
who aren't afraid of that madmen and
Stoics you know they are the people have
you ever read any stoicism you know you
know when you hear the word stoic you
just think of like like like Germans
with lifeless doll eyes yeah there's a
reason for that the the the Greek school
of thought that we know is first ISM
they will I mean there's a lot in there
that's good you know Newt you're
responsible for everything you do you
know so you take the personal
responsibility of everything you do and
the only the only way things can affect
you is if you let them affect you so you
know if if you're you know I can't leave
an example now but if you know if
somebody happens to you that's our guy
you have no fats if someone triggers you
on the internet then it's up to you not
true right but then they then they take
this to its extreme signal if you're
being tortured that's your fault right
and you know if you're in tremendous
pain that's your fault as well it's okay
okay calm down I don't think that when
you're being tortured you can reasonably
say well you should have known it was
going to come for this because you know
that seems like a bit of a stretch to me
but that's that's getting into leftism
with women raped by Muslims well you
shouldn't have not worn the burqa they
show your yeah yeah exactly
well did you ever see the United States
the the liberal sorry leader the
Democrat advocacy for how to prevent
rape did you receive that no I was like
I'm out screaming urinating yourself you
never heard about this it was Jamaica
wrong ha ha ha
it was to make yourself as unappealing
to be raped as possible this was
actually like given out as a pamphlet
like try and throw up you're in the
moment you know it's like oh hang on a
sec I don't know I need to written by
Nicole Richie I assume Jesus yeah that's
I've not heard that but oh yeah well we
can bring that up sometime now that
we're talking about our people can go to
I think we covered it louder with Carter
calm it was like it was actually like
handing out which was so funny because
it goes against this idea right of
feminism that rape is never a crime oh
yeah sex of power but it's like well if
it's a crime of power they wouldn't care
if you pee yourself exactly they're not
doing it because they find you
attractive they're doing it because they
wouldn't suffer but I'm not really down
with that narrative at all I've gotta
say I don't I don't like it I disagree
that the kinky in yourself or that rape
is an act of power almost like I'm the
gangs both yeah that's fair but yeah the
rape smacks of power I think that there
are there are definitely circumstances
where rape is an act of power like male
prison but I don't think for most people
that's the case I think that for most
because the reason I says because like
most rapes are committed by someone who
knows the victim and a lot of time it's
in an intimate setting where for example
they might they might have a
relationship or something like that but
um but then things go farther than the
woman would like and
the gains of raping her I I think in
situations like that rape is probably an
act of passion
rather than an act of power I don't
think it's necessarily the guy trying to
dominate the woman I think that you know
biologically his blood is up and and I'm
not in any way trying to excuse this and
this is what Nina this is why every
small rape so he lost control of himself
and all that so things maybe I also
think it's very unfair to take let's say
a couple who are have in the middle of
having sex and obviously if a woman ever
says no no means no but I was think it's
very unfair broken up that me oh can you
not hear me
can you hear me now what's happening is
he going is this going all is this going
is his internet Breck sitting can you
not hear me analyze I can he now oh can
you hear me I'm sorry yeah can you you
know you sing something well I think
it's I also think it's unfair for let's
say a couple long term couple having sex
and the woman they're having sex and
then she doesn't enjoy the sex she's
like stop and the guy maybe goes on
longer than you supposed to horrible yes
probably a germ but it's not the same as
violent rape it doesn't make it
acceptable but and then you scale that
back even further regretful sex as Lena
Dunham wants you to believe and that's
not rape oh yeah I not agree there are
don't see differences in severity from
these crime but some but yeah the the
narrative that rape isn't always about
power I don't buy I think a lot of the
time it's about passion I think makes
any better no no it does it doesn't make
it any better but again it's it's
something that they set to make it seem
as though men willingly are more mean
spirit because women go like well I
would never do that just out of power as
though there isn't some innate sexual
attraction it makes men seem much more
like monsters than impulsive which both
are bad yeah
now are we talking alright or talking
could you talk about this about rape
within Islam it's very much about power
in his on its yes in Islamic cultures it
is I mean I told the story about the cab
driver who said he was gonna he was
going to eff me in my family before we
went home to my dad
and it's like a very common thing their
insults are not like eff you it's like
I'm going to copulate
with you we ran this all the time in
Montreal yeah I talk I've told the story
too many times on the show but because
Sargon's privilege privilege a little
face he's never ever been a a soulless
way you ever heard about this yeah oh
yeah that's why there's all kinds of
pedophilia and stuff in Islam yeah he
this was really common I'm ever add even
like friends in high school where they
would sit like make these insults these
Muslims that was pretty gay no no it's
not gay it was like you just said you're
gonna screw him and that sounds pretty
good
there was a cab driver one time who cut
off my dad and my dad cut him off and he
yelled cabbie suck and I remember this
because my dad I've told this story
before so don't abort the ayats but I
learned something for my dad if ever
someone is pulling up on the side of the
pulling up on you walking up to your car
he unlatched the car door but didn't
open it he said why because if that
person wants to keep you in and either
shoot you or come through the door with
us let whatever it is you're exposed but
you also don't want to open the door so
he can just grab it yank it open so you
open it just enough so it's unlocked and
as he comes up boom you can you can
dictate the terms and knock him back and
get out if you need to protect your
family so that's how I remember this
very clearly and the cab driver came out
with his cane and was actually doing
this like a probing motion and he said I
am going to sorry people listening sorry
mama I'm going to [ __ ] you I am going to
[ __ ] you and your family before you go
home and around smart ass kid I guess
like you can but it was very common and
that's because in certain in certain I
mean cultures it is a dominant thing I
mean there is there is an aspect and it
is in domineering cultures you'll find
it yes I mean the Vikings used to do the
same thing you know they they didn't
really discriminate who they raped when
they were pillaging anything with a hole
in a lot of cases so sometimes it is
about power but I think the majority of
rapes are probably about passion
although with the Vikings probably was
worst you probably had some women who
like the Vikings always could ransack
their village in they were just never
rape a certain way
so what I wanted to I watched your
communism video your refutation of
communism and it was very good apart
from one thing
where which one mother karl marx okay
yeah yeah the Marx one yeah yeah the the
distinction between private and personal
property is one you didn't make and I
don't blame you because it's easy to
think that what they mean is you can't
own anything but there is and and I made
this mistake myself until some communist
that kindly decided to come and comment
on a video I'd mentioned in and but yeah
but basically the the distinction is
personal property is just the stuff you
own and you you're apparently okay to
own it a private property one they say
that and I don't know why they don't use
more specific language but it's actually
not like you know the things you
privately own it's frankly the means of
production so anything if you have like
a workshop and you wanted to employ an
assistant to be able to make something
with you so you could sell something
that would be the means of production
that would be private property rather
than your personal property and so you
would have to I don't know do some so on
I don't know give it up to the state
yeah I have some sort of sharing
agreement with the guy I don't really
know what the solution isn't that that
means production you mean yeah but the
point is it's about collective ownership
of the means of production so if you had
a workshop you wanted to hire an
assistant you would have to give the
assistant part ownership of your
workshop okay couple of things there I
it's been a while since I've done the
video so for those people listening I
always say you probably remember
everything you've talked about but if I
remember correctly the video I did
address means of production and private
property separately because they issued
those separately so they didn't know
when they say private property they mean
the means of production but they talked
about private property and then went on
to describe separately later on the
video means of production so they were
the ones who made original video the
original video that I was in feuding I
do remember that because no no but
you're right you're right and I still
disagree with you but you're right and I
remember going this video is misleading
because I think the maker of the
video deliberately wanted to separate it
because the maker of the video was even
further to the left than Karl Marx
despite them trying to act objective and
if people actually watch it and gush up
like watch their video on Adam Smith
it's remarkably different like one is
clearly advocacy and one is like this
guy kind of believe this the invisible
hand of the market you get that a lot
there there are quite a lot of
philosophy YouTube channels I follow and
you can the younger ones are all very
much and honestly I wouldn't quite go as
far as they can focus II but it's
definitely bordering on advocacy for
Marx right pan I really bothered by this
because I mean Karl Marx was a very
intelligent man obviously he and he did
have a very sound critique of capitalism
and he did have a lot of good ideas the
problem is none of them translated into
his proposed solutions which were
terrible
in every single way and you there I mean
I can't believe that people can look at
communism on paper and go yeah this will
work this will obviously not work right
this this will obviously end up with
gulags this is built into the text
almost that anyone who only in Islam
does exactly the same it's about the
in-group out-group dichotomy the the
first thing a Muslim terrorists do is
declared that the other Muslims they're
killing in Baghdad or wherever aren't
Muslims because if the part of the
in-group you're not allowed to do
anything to them if they're part of a
group you are allowed to do things to
them and it's the same communism with
the proletariat and the bourgeoisie
you would just go ahead and declare
anyone you want to be bourgeoisie and
then then they're in a capitalist
oppressor and it's okay to do whatever
you want to them drag them from their
decadent culture exactly and this is
built into the Communist Manifesto it's
it's built-ins communism itself and
right honestly I've been planning on
doing a video for ages just because I
can't see how people can't can't predict
where this is going and there's a reason
that in practically every country that's
adopted communism in fact I can't think
of a country this is dr. communism and
hasn't had a bloody purge of the
opposition right and I don't think
that's a coincidence no and I know
you're absolutely right and
to go back to your point that the
criticism which I understand I want to
say I was responding to a video so
that's important secondly yeah even if I
weren't so that's the context because
they said private property and then go
on to means a production even if I
weren't and here's the thing where I
think there's a disconnect ok so we
talked about private property so I don't
want to be misrepresentative
what would you say like like maybe your
house maybe your own personal that's
that's the difference private property
is something you own okay it produces
something personal property is something
you own okay doesn't do so personal
property so let's say yes so let's
assume that this is the video wasn't and
let's take your kind of premise here
because again that was addressing a
video not what you're bringing up but
but this is also personal property let's
say that would be would it be like let's
say your house your furniture maybe
you're spending about how you finish
you're absolutely right whatever
personal means you have yes okay well
here's the thing that people understand
how do you think that the means of
production is created from a business
owner well that's the question isn't it
it is always from personal property me
everything you see was a savings account
hired not gay Jarrod The Young Turks
whether you give the video the makeup
all that stuff comes from personal
property and that's the thing you can't
really separate the two because all of a
sudden there's a means of production
this is why communism outside of a few
weapons really hasn't created a whole
lot it hasn't been particularly
innovative because people's toilet the
space toilet people are incentivized to
use their own personal property for said
personal property to create eventually
what is private property means of
production the ability to employ yeah
there it can't happen and government
can't create that so you could have a
system where you know you petition the
government with a proposal and say okay
I want to open a a people's supermarket
down the street and you know I want you
know I want to get the money to put it
all but I mean and you could do all this
but it would be massively in effect
inefficient but how do you do it if
there are no people taking risk in no
wealth creators well you would have
obviously some sort of government
official that decided yes or no yeah but
who are they tax if no one creates
anything again no one is using their
personal property to create private
means at a certain point it can only
live off the backs yeah established by
communist societies are always piss-poor
no but understand because argument you
brought up in and I don't say this
because I know you're very intelligent
your honor I'm not saying star ganas
ignore stupid what I'm saying is that's
taught in colleges in contrary I play it
ignorant conservative on TV I've learned
all that stuff in college and the
disconnect is people don't understand
because again the sort of Citizens
United corporations aren't people yeah
they are down the line someone took a
personal risk and created that means of
production and so there's a
sleight-of-hand where no no no we're not
talking about this desk we're not
talking about your house we're talking
about the the factory that built all of
that well hold on how did that factory
get created well someone was in a house
like you with that stuff and they put it
up as collateral or they saved but we
don't talk about them and people just
don't think enough far enough down the
line because at the end of it there is
but I think there's also a distinction
to be made here because I mean this this
seems to be the reason why we have
limited liability companies if your
company goes under and you lots of money
you don't lose your house because you're
on limited liability so it doesn't apply
to an LLC I know I don't know if it's an
S because I saw my pass-through entity
for like you can't be sued but I don't
know it's like a corporation where again
I don't in in Britain you can be a
limited company which means that you
don't end up losing everything you owned
if the company goes under okay the
company just loses everything if taken
by the banks or whoever and so yeah I
mean the the distinction though is a a
if you've got that protection then you
can't really say well you know this is
just a this is my personal property
because I created I have nothing I said
well if you're not if you don't think we
have responsible for any problems that
come along in the company going under
then why should you then also have the
benefit of saying what's my personal
property but B I think that when it gets
to a certain size there's there does
have to be some sort of cutoff point
where you accept that this has gone
beyond just your personal business you
know when you're an international
corporation you're employing tens of
thousands of people you're pumping out
massive massive say carbon
whatever kind of things in the
environment you know you've got it
changes depending on the car of yours
there's definitely a degree of
responsibility for the sort of weight of
impact your company can have sure so I I
do agree I definitely think that there's
there is a point at which it stops being
just a small mother a mom-and-pop thing
and becomes a corporation where it's
something separate and it's it's its own
sort of institution by now but I but I
do agree that you know that you might
these things do usually start as small
businesses that grow and grow and grow
and that because they're successful so I
mean frankly I didn't I don't like the
idea of starting small business and then
being told it's the people's business
right but then it becomes a question of
okay is it the government's right to
take over Starbucks when it's one store
when it's five or when it's five
thousand when does the government get to
say you've made enough on your
investment now it's ours and that's a
question no no communist has answered
successfully yeah but we don't we don't
the government doesn't take over private
corporations which I private property
means of production yeah I know but I
mean this yeah we don't we we allow
these things to remain private
right but now I'm not under communism oh
yeah oh my god and communism I don't
know I know and I was still in the
communism threat that's what I was yes I
mean I think it was a good idea we're
arguing it seems I'm saying this is a
terrible no no I understand because I
think I saw that criticism maybe by some
people well first off you always have
taken context if we're addressing
someone's like for example we argue
about the idea it's not a big deal it
was just a small thing you know that
just before the Communist pedants turn
up on your video going you're wrong
Steven because it happens all the time
it happens like the Young Turks even
from people who like a whip say like
well why did you dress a militia why
don't you a dress like because we did
that in another video we're addressing
this argument right now I don't have
time for all of it it was a good video
it was on point
well thank you I try and you know what I
think I think I think the reason why
we're having these conversations
I remember listen I remember when
YouTube write was it was there were a
lot of dumb Christian
there who YouTube was anyone could
upload it which is like you had kids
we're just uploading themselves you know
having SuperSoaker fights right
and so these Christians would go on with
these very very I guess sort of
misinformed
I guess textbook apologetics and try and
take on debates that they couldn't
handle and and I certainly don't feel
qualified in the room because I've been
around other either Christian apologists
or scientists where I just want to sit
and listen so I do think for a long time
it was like The Young Turks who I think
we're just as unreasonable back then and
then yet but they looked more reasonable
in the face of a lot of sort of self
yeah yeah come on well if if there's if
there's evolution that how come the
monkeys aren't how come the monkeys
aren't changing right now and like God
yeah yeah exactly and I was rolling my
eyes just as much as you are I'm not
gonna wade into that firefight because
after half of the time speaking is
apologizing for some guy I don't even
know but I think it's good now I think I
think call I think listen I think
politically the country is probably it's
probably going to go Clinton most likely
unfortunately but I think channels like
yours and what we do you think it's
gonna be Trump I think I think that it's
more likely from Trump and Clinton now
after the DNC linked leaks and the
splitting of the party effectively I
mean you know I don't think a lot of
Bernie supporters are gonna vote Clinton
i watch i watch loads of videos from
people who are just interviewing them on
the protests and they're like yeah never
Hillary she's never gonna get my vote
and there are thousands of these people
as a Christ man you know maybe maybe
Hillary is kind of a bit maybe she's a
bit the house of cards
maybe my thought process is there hasn't
been a huge bump out of the RNC there
was a CNN poll but then there were other
polls that came out and still have
Clinton leading by maybe one maybe
Trump's ahead by you know a couple
points in the back so once I sold Trump
was ahead by a few points not many know
that was a CNN poll but there was
another one that came out so I mean it
could be obvious I'd much rather
obviously might rather see Trump win
than Hillary Clinton I'm not a fan of
either but you know they didn't see a
huge bump now at the after the DNC
leagues there will be a DNC bump and
then we're left with one thing we're
left with okay wherever we are the
game-changer is either an October
Surprise of which the Clintons are the
best in all of political hist
the October Surprise some kind of
last-minute bomb and the debates and
Donald Trump isn't very good in the
realm of debate and Hillary Clinton is
that if she's not having a seizure she's
actually pretty good I don't know I mean
the thing is Donald Trump doesn't have
the debate his opponents want to have
it's true that's that's the that's the
the power of Donald Trump when it comes
to debates he plays the crowd he's not
he's not arguing the issues and Hillary
does not have the charisma to play the
crowd at all and you know that you know
I'm sure you know that like people
people care people don't judge a debate
on who's factually right
they judge a debate on who seems most
confident around Donald Trump's gonna
steamroll her III can't wait to see
Donald Trump and Hillary Clinton going
at it it's but I hope they're right but
I don't think so have you seen her
speeches on the campaign trail recently
like with when now that she's full steam
ahead against Trump there was those one
was she was having a coughing fit yeah
no I mean she's just so Jarrett naki
here now we're talking about this it's
um
she just sits there and someone goes you
know what about Donald I'm making
America great again she just goes I
already think America is great now and
the audience laughs and all of a sudden
she's flipped it where she's the patriot
and Trump hates America or where she
says legal what about Donald Trump's
business experience so she's been
coached very very well what about Donald
Trump's business experience she goes
well yeah but what the federal
government
you can't just file bankruptcy and the
audience laughs and so I think she's
prepped and I think she's twisted in it
where she's this sort of patriotic
pro-american candidate running against
somebody who doesn't like the country
who's doom-and-gloom who's pushing fear
and I don't know I think it's
interesting how it will play I wouldn't
bet on this either way the Vegas betting
odds still favor Hillary but yeah I
wouldn't be so there's not much in it
the thing is I don't think you can
reasonably portray Donald Trump as being
empty America I think anyone who tries
to do that it's going to come off the
worst because he's so obviously pro
America you know he's he's so obviously
pro America and I think I think one of
Donald Trump's appeals and something I
mean I particularly like man is the
assessment
America and very it's very easy for a
politician to do a Hillary and go well I
think America is great we're ready it's
okay but there are millions of people
having a rough time right now who don't
think America is very great and Donald
Trump is actually speaking directly to
them on the issues that they actually
care about and you know one thing I
found very strange about Donald Trump is
he's surprisingly empathetic for what
you've I was gonna say for Donald Trump
but for the for the image of double
trouble if people haven't the image he
portrays on you know when in these
debates and stuff but when when you
watch him Tom Phoebe you can see he
actually is listening and he's don't see
listening for a few key data points that
he can pull out of what they're saying
that he can then Mena use in his next
speech or something like that but right
he does listen and he is genuinely
talking to these points that that there
is a large segment of the population who
care about whereas I don't think Hillary
Clinton is doing that and I don't think
that she's really got the fortitude to
turn her and say well you know we're
getting killed on trade with China
because you probably are I don't know if
he about it but I'm sure you are because
no one ever criticizes Trump on that
point you know all they say is well he's
making all these hats in China is that
yes that's what he's saying right that's
exactly his point you know he's
literally saying like we're getting
killed in China I know because I make my
clip my stuff there and that needs to
change and the honest criticism I think
is appealing you know I think I think is
I think that's true I think that's true
and I think it's you know it's one of
the things I don't think anyone really
knows where this is going I do think
that Donald Trump if he's not ahead he
tends to he tends to fold a little bit
and we saw that with the Republican
debates I always said he'll be
remarkably soft on Hillary to what
people think and you see now he's more
busy attacking Ted Cruz and Hillary
Clinton hopefully he pivots he hasn't
really yet he attacks her when he has to
but he's still busy focusing on the
Republican Party it could go either way
but here's the my point regardless
whether Hillary wins or not channels
like yours channels like mine could have
never existed a few years ago never ever
it wouldn't have been allowed it
wouldn't been acceptable so culturally I
think you have a lot of younger people
who are either transitioning away from
The Young Turks or because the Young
Turks have gone in saying whatever your
viewpoint it is cool to see that that
culturally speaking people like you and
I who four years ago we would have
like everyone would have wanted us to
hate each other corn isn't oh yeah we
would have been we would have been
fighting over something I'm sure
something over well like today when you
tried to argue communist I mean believe
this district have to pick something
great okay well this is by the way for
those watching the web extended right
now because this might I don't know
started on make it then this on his
channel or not this is because of it was
playing jank earlier and I couldn't wipe
off all the bronzer so he was doing
blackface
well not gay Jared did for a cultural
appropriate did not never happen that's
right it never happened you were Rachel
Dolezal tonight you're getting to a
stated me how yes exactly
Oh Lord Sargon have a cat thank you very
much sir I appreciate it end up always
always always welcome to come back my
pleasure mate alright like this video
you might be a little disturbed but this
is taken from the full weekly free
podcast video cast you can click to see
the full show down there or my face to
go to ladder with credit calm there are
more articles and you see here on
YouTube or below me for another video if
you don't click any of them that's fine
but expect anthrax in your mailbox